The Marvel Cinematic Universe
is getting godly in Phase 4.
"Eternals," the 26th movie in the sprawling MCU,
is hitting theaters in 2021, about a team
of heroes you may know nothing about. Here's
everything you need to know about "Eternals,"
and how the film fits into Marvel's Phase 4.
"You are about to meet the greatest
warriors the world has ever known."
"Eternals" was officially announced on
July 20, 2019 at Comic-Con in San Diego,
with a slated premiere date of November
6, 2020. Unfortunately, when the
coronavirus pandemic inevitably led to a total
reshuffling of the MCU slate, things changed.
With theaters around the world shuttered,
"Black Widow" ultimately ended up being
moved to May 2021, making 2020 the first
year without a Marvel movie since 2009.
"Eternals" was given a new release date of
November 5, 2021. Fortunately, this schedule
actually stuck. Marvel fans have been hearing news
about a film based on the Eternals comics being in
the works since the spring of 2018 — three and a
half years later, they'll finally get to see it.
Even longtime Marvel fans might not be too
knowledgeable about who the Eternals are
and their role in the Marvel Universe. After all,
they appeared in a relatively limited run of comic
books in the mid 1970s and '80s. The storyline was
revived for a miniseries by Neil Gaiman in 2006,
which brought these characters
into the modern Marvel universe.
So, who are the Eternals, and what is their
significance? According to Marvel lore,
an alien species called the Celestials
visited Earth millions of years ago
and began carrying out experiments
on the inhabitants. Naturally,
the results of these experiments weren't
always a net positive for our planet.
The Celestials were the original creators
of the Eternals, beings that looked like
humans yet possessed abilities like flight, mind
reading, and unbelievable strength and endurance.
Their superpowers and resilience made them
essentially immortal and indestructible.
But the Celestials' experiments were also
responsible for the creation of the Deviants,
another group of humanoids who were burdened
with genetic mutations and typically grotesque
in appearance. Humans mistook Eternals for
gods, and the Eternals often clashed with
the Deviants to protect humanity. However, the
Eternals weren't unfailingly perfect — as we'll
likely see in the film, they can be misled
and instigate conflicts among themselves.
At this point, we've met countless characters
from the original Marvel comics in the MCU.
Have we been introduced to any
of the Eternals yet? Sort of.
It hasn't been mentioned in the movies yet,
but Thanos, the most formidable enemy of the
Avengers so far, was actually the child of
Eternals. If that seems a little confusing,
that's understandable — the Eternals
were supposed to be protecting humanity,
not wiping it out, and they should be
able to physically blend in among humans.
However, it's safe to say that
Thanos was a bit of a wild card,
because he also possessed a recessive Deviant
gene, which explains his purply appearance.
Obviously lots of things can change in
the journey from the comics to the MCU,
so we wouldn't necessarily use him as an
example of the Eternals or Deviants to come.
Given that the MCU has never shied
away from streamlining or changing
its characters' dense histories for the screen,
it's entirely possible that Thanos' comic history
as an Eternal-Deviant hybrid may not even come up.
"Eternals" actually shares a connection with
another film in the MCU. In "Guardians of
the Galaxy Vol. 2," Peter Quill's father,
Ego, tells Peter that he is a Celestial.
"Celestial like a god?"
"Small 'g,' son."
He's portrayed as extremely powerful and possesses
god-like abilities. Ego is millions of years old,
and he is able to manipulate the matter around
him. By the time we meet him in "Guardians Vol.
2," he has managed to form a whole planet around
himself, but he can also inhabit a human body.
Yet all of this wasn't enough for Ego. He
eventually became bored with mere immortality and
decided that he wanted to turn all of the worlds
in the cosmos into extensions of himself. But he
wasn't capable of doing this alone, so he needed
another Celestial to help him turn his idea into
reality. That's exactly why he became a father
in the first place — he hoped his son Peter would
become his accomplice, and to ensure that his son
wouldn't be led astray, Ego killed Peter's mother.
When Peter found out that Ego was
responsible for his mother's death,
he turned against Ego, and the Guardians teamed
up to destroy him. Clearly, the Celestials can
have nefarious intentions, and they're not an
all-powerful force for good in the universe.
The cast of "Eternals" is rounded out with both
rising stars and A-listers. Richard Madden,
who rose to fame for playing
the ill-fated Robb Stark in
"Game of Thrones," has signed on to play Ikaris.
Ikaris was known as the "Prime Eternal" in the
comics, meaning that he was more powerful than
the other Eternals. He is fueled by cosmic energy,
and he can move at super speed and communicate
telepathically. His sheer physical strength and
agility makes him a formidable opponent in combat.
"What is this even made of? Vibranium?"
"Don't-"
And speaking of "Game of Thrones," Kit Harington,
who is best known for playing Jon Snow,
is in the "Eternals" cast as Dane Whitman.
Whitman isn't an Eternal himself, but he is
a superhero who goes by the name the Black
Knight -- and it's likely that he'll have
a prominent place in future Marvel films,
one way or another. You may not have heard
of him, but it's worth mentioning that he's
been a member of the Avengers -- and sometimes
even the team's leader -- for a very long time.
"Who do you think's gonna lead the Avengers?"
"I could lead them."
Ridloff was born Deaf, and as one
of the few Deaf actors in Hollywood,
she has always wanted to see more
representation for her community onscreen.
Now, she's made film history as the first
explicitly deaf superhero in the MCU.
Her casting also represents a major change
from the original comics — her character
Makkari was actually a male character, and he
wasn't written as deaf. But the reception to
this change has been overwhelmingly positive
so far, and fans are generally looking forward
to seeing Ridloff's portrayal of Makkari,
an Eternal with the power of super speed.
Angelina Jolie plays the ageless Eternal, Thena,
in the "Eternals" cast — a major
get for the MCU, to say the least.
In the Marvel Universe, the city of Athens, Greece
was actually built for Thena, not the goddess
Athena as most would naturally assume. And that's
no inconsequential mix-up; human beings confusing
Thena and Athena bred hostility between the
Eternals and the Olympic gods of Greek mythology,
eventually leading to an all out war. In Gaiman's
"Eternals" comics, Thena works as a researcher
at Stark Enterprises and starts remembering her
past as an Eternal through recurring nightmares.
Jolie is definitely the biggest name
attached to the "Eternals" cast,
and maybe the MCU in general, and she's ecstatic
to be part of the evolving on-screen universe.
Speaking at San Diego Comic-Con, she said,
"I'm going to work ten times harder.
I know what we all need to do,
we have all read the script, we
all know what the task ahead is,
and we know what you deserve, so we are
all going to be working very, very hard."
When Marvel initially revealed the main
"Eternals" cast members at Comic-Con,
they left audiences in suspense
about who would be playing Sersi.
At Disney's D23 Expo it was announced
that Gemma Chan had landed the role.
As an Eternal, Sersi possesses powers like
transmutation, mind control, and flight. However,
she also loves living among humans. She eventually
becomes a famous party planner in New York City,
entertaining her guests with magic
that they believe is mere illusion.
Chan actually has a previous, unrelated role in
the MCU as the Kree warrior Minn-Erva, last seen
getting blown up near the end of "Captain Marvel."
She's ecstatic to be joining the "Eternals"
cast and having the opportunity to play a new
character in the MCU, posting on Twitter in 2019,
"I couldn't be happier to be coming back
to the MCU to play this iconic character
and to work with this incredible group of people."
Chan isn't the only rising star joining the
"Eternals" cast. At D23, it was revealed that
Barry Keoghan will officially be playing Druig.
Druig does have superpowers, but he doesn't use
them for good — he's the villain of the film,
wreaking havoc in the cosmos and on Earth.
Keoghan has wanted to join
the MCU for a while — in fact,
he even tweeted to Stan Lee
about it in 2013, writing,
Stan Lee, Please Make me a SuperHero :).
Now, he's finally achieved his goal.
Keoghan caught the attention of
critics with his performance as
George Mills in the Academy
Award-winning film "Dunkirk"
and went on to star in the psychological
thriller "The Killing of a Sacred Deer."
Most recently, he played a role in two episodes of
the critically acclaimed HBO series "Chernobyl."
Druig definitely represents a different
type of role for Keoghan, but clearly,
he's been waiting years for a shot at landing
a part in the MCU. Now, it's his time to shine.
Overall, the cast of "Eternals" is
stacked, with a few other names new
to superherodom that you'll probably recognize.
Kumail Nanjiani will be playing Kingo, an
Eternal with a day job as a major Bollywood star.
Brian Tyree Henry will be appearing as Phastos,
who basically develops all of the high-tech
gear and equipment that the Eternals need.
In an apparent first for Marvel, Lebanese actor
Haaz Sleiman will be appearing in "Eternals" as
Phastos' husband, making him one half of the
first openly gay relationship in the MCU.
Salma Hayek has signed on to play
Ajak, who often has to serve as a
diplomat between the Eternals and the
Celestials. This is because Ajak was
originally the only Eternal with the ability
to directly communicate with the Celestials.
Don Lee is taking on the role of Gilgamesh, an
Eternal who in the comics has fought alongside
the Avengers on numerous occasions, but
has been essentially overlooked until now.
Finally, Lia McHugh, the youngest member of
the main cast, is playing Sprite — as the name
suggests, she's a mischievous trickster whose
pranks have always gotten her into trouble.
Director Chloe Zhao will be
at the helm of "Eternals."
Zhao is a newcomer to the world of Marvel.
These days, of course, Zhao is best
known as the director of "Nomadland."
The film won three Academy
Awards, including Best Picture
and Best Director, making Zhao the second woman
in history to secure an Oscar for directing.
Zhao's history as an indie filmmaker turned
Oscar winner makes her an interesting choice
for the director of Eternals. This film
definitely represents a new artistic
direction for the filmmaker, but there's
no doubt that the movie is in good hands.
Young Syrian actor Zain Al
Rafeea has a supporting role
in "Eternals" -- and it may be a significant one.
While he only appears briefly in
the movie's teaser and trailer,
apparently as a prehistoric human, Salma Hayek
posted a photo with Lia McHugh and Al Rafeea,
with the caption, "Hanging with the
Eternals' youth." Al Rafeea himself
hinted that he might be playing Namor the
Sub-Mariner, an Atlantean prince and mutant.
Time will tell whether or not these
rumors have any truth to them,
but if "Eternals" opens the door
to Marvel's undersea kingdom,
and the story of the first mutant,
it'll be even more of a must-see movie.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.